Taylor Swift dropped her new album lover
and Scooter Braun has thoughts the 38
year old manager took to social to speak
out bold move right he tweeted quote
regardless of what has been said the
truth is you don't make big bets unless
you are a believer and always have been
brilliant album with lover scooter added
congrats Taylor Swift supporting was
always the healthier option brilliant
album brilliant campaign Congrats what
of course some of Taylor's loyal fans
went in on scooter slamming him in the
comments and telling him to quote get a
job and stay away from her do not mess
with Swifties dude just a quick
refresher on the drama between Taylor
and scooter scooter recently bought the
rights to Taylor's masters from her
first five albums in a three hundred
million dollar deal when he joined Big
Machine Records then Taylor publicly
slammed the deal claiming she quote
pleaded for a chance to own her work but
was instead quote given an opportunity
to sign back up to Big Machine Records
and earn one album back at a time one
for every new one I turned in while
Taylor was all like no thanks leaving
Big Machine and signing with Universal
oh and let's not forget in that same
post she called out scooter for quote
incessant manipulative bullying adding
essentially my musical legacy is about
to lie in the hands of someone who tried
to dismantle it brutal then in July
Taylor appeared to throw shade at
scooter when she performed shake it off
at the amazon prime date concert well
you've been getting down
about the liars and the dirty dirty
cheats of the world
[Music]
I mean she really emphasized liars and
dirty dirty cheats of the world
I think that artists deserved to own
their work I just feel very passionately
about that well Taylor found a way to
stick it to the man revealing recently
that she plans to re-record her old
music that's true and it's something
that I'm very excited about doing
because my contract says that starting
November 2020 so next year I can record
albums 1 through 5 all over again so in
the meantime Taylor is holding her head
high like the regal Queen she is one
thing about this album that's really
special to me is that it's the first one
that I will own I feel like scooters
intentions might have been good but
maybe a private text to Taylor would
have been better
yikes of course et will be right here to
keep you totally filled in on all things
Taylor Swift so make sure to keep it
coming back until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens bye for now
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]